Raymond Stern, thank you so much
for being on the show
20 Minute Leaders
I really appreciate it.
My pleasure. Glad to be here.
This is gonna be so much fun.
And I'm not gonna be able to do justice
for the insane amount of things
that you've done.
But just as a brief venture,
you did Stanford for your undergrad.
Very proud of that.
And then a Harvard MBA.
Moved on to consulting.
A senior vice president positions
at Intuit and Yahoo
Venture Capital,
a very successful venture capital
and clear path over
the past several years.
But you've also done
the entrepreneurial journey yourself,
which I'd love to hear more about.
Raymond, there's so many things
I want to ask you.
I want to talk about leadership.
I want to talk about scaling,
about team building.
But can you give me a little bit
of a brief intro about who you are
and what excites you?
Yeah. A lot of things excite me,
but I love, I guess first and foremost,
I love helping entrepreneurs.
When I think about my own career,
the thing that I got the biggest kick out
of was helping coach and mentor people,
whether it was at BCG
when I was a partner there
and actually, before I was a partner there
or whether I was at Yahoo or Intuit,
and certainly the work
I do today with entrepreneurs.
And so, that's where I get my biggest kick.
And the thing that gives me the biggest
amount of pride when I meet with people
over time, many years later,
is to see the great things
they've gone on to do
because they're amazingly capable
and feeling like maybe I had one tiny,
tiny little aspect of that
in helping them along the way.
So, looking at these various experiences
from an entrepreneur consultant
and then venture capital,
where do you most attracted to
if you had to choose of these three fields?
So, let me just clarify.
Venture capital, I don't do
a lot of venture capital.
My work is mainly helping
entrepreneurs with my time.
And every so often I invest.
But I just wanted to clarify that
for your audience.
Sure.
Where I really get my kick
is working with the entrepreneurs.
You know, I love my experiences at
BCG and Intuit and at Yahoo.
But I really, really enjoy
the startup environment much more.
And for one main reason.
One, because you can just
get stuff done.
And the pace at which
these organizations move
is radically different than
what you can do at an Intuit or Yahoo
or any larger company.
Now, I think there's a lot to learn
from those larger companies,
especially as you're trying to scale a business.
And hopefully that's part of what
I bring to the clients that I work with.
Right. Okay.
So, how many entrepreneurs
would you say you've got to work with
or lend a hand
over these past several decades?
Probably 25 or 30,
where I've really worked with them
pretty intimately.
And at this point in time right now,
I'm working probably actively
with about 10 or 12.
Wow.
And the great thing is
when I work with entrepreneurs,
it tends to be on a long-term basis.
I mean, these are relationships
that I've built over time.
And I get to see them from
the early, early days to companies
that are selling for billions of dollars.
And I've gone on to do some
pretty incredible things.
So, it's a long-term relationship.
And I really enjoy
watching that evolution
and the amazing things they do
with their teams
to build great companies.
Incredible. Okay.
Let's start with your executive positions
within Intuit
and Yahoo's Senior Vice President.
You're basically you're there.
You're helping lead
these billion-dollar businesses
and leave strategy.
What does that even entail?
What is the role
of a senior vice president
at these two incredible companies?
And what are some of the key takeaways
that you would take from those times?
You know, each role is different.
And that depends on the functions
and your meetings.
I have a great opportunity to lead.
As you mentioned, some strategy armaments.
But I also got to lead
a marketing organization.
When I was at Yahoo,
I led the small business
I'm sorry.
In Intuit I lead a small business division.
When I was at Yahoo,
Got a brisk opportunity to lead
some of our operations internationally.
So, it's a pretty diverse set of things.
And obviously you've got to have some
expertise in the area of leading.
But the thing that's common
with every single one of them
is you've got to lead.
I mean, at the end of the day,
when you're at that level
in an organization,
your role is primarily
getting the right people in the organization
and getting them aligned
on the critical priorities
for the organization
and then ensuring
that you're making progress
against those priorities.
And if you're not putting in place processes
to course correct
and get back on track
and things like that.
But ultimately the common
thing is one of leadership.
Assuming you have some reasonable amount
of domain expertise,
because at that level you're not.
You can't roll up your sleeves
and do everything. Right?
I mean, the organizations are complex
and there's a lot going on
which is very different
than when you're an early stage
entrepreneur.
Where you're rolling up
your sleeves and doing everything.
And one of the challenges
entrepreneurs face as they scale
and grow their organizations
is making that transition
from I do everything
to a higher rate people.
And now I've got to make sure
that they do great work
and have also taken enable that
in a way that's powerful.
So, I'm going to ask a weird question.
What are some of the worst things
that person at the level of
a senior vice president
at a big company can do in
terms of leadership?
What are some of the don'ts that,
because a lot of the times people
and I ask what should I keep in mind?
And what should I do as a leader?
I want to know what I shouldn't do.
What are some things
that I don't realize
that I might do
and I want to avoid them purposefully?
Yeah, sure. And actually,
the flip side of it
is what makes them great.
So, a negative to negative
then just turn it around
and you'll understand the good part.
I think oftentimes leaders
don't get clarity
on what they're solving for.
And they need to understand
what are the critical levers
that they're responsible for,
that are gonna drive
whatever outcomes they need to drive
to support the success of the company.
That's one thing.
So, if you don't do that,
you're screwed.
Because you're gonna go off
and do stuff in the wrong direction.
Second thing that leaders
don't do as well as they should sometimes
is make sure that everyone is aligned on that.
Because you might know what you're doing.
But if you don't get the entire organization
aligned on the same things,
you're gonna get people going
in disparate directions.
And at the end of the day,
you won't get to the end result
that you're looking for.
Right.
And there's a whole list of things.
But I think the one that
most leaders fail to appreciate
how powerful it can be
if they get it right
is how they allocate their time.
Because if you think about it
learning, if you wanna impact outcomes,
you can learn new skills.
But that can take years
or weeks or months.
Whereas you can decide again
in a heartbeat,
I'm going to stop doing this
and start doing this,
and then you'll have a better impact
on those things.
And that was an early lesson I had
working for a great leader
who came out of GE.
You got him Steve Bennett,
who I worked for many years
when I was at Intuit.
And I just found that to be
incredibly powerful.
And I think people who don't
manage their time well
fail as leaders.
Whether at a Fortune 500 company
or a brand-new startup.
The most critical thing
you need to think about is,
where am I gonna spend my time?
Because that's the most
precious commodity you have.
And at a Fortune 500 company,
you're generally not worried
about having enough money,
whereas the most precious commodity
startup has is just making sure
they have enough oxygen.
Definitely.
I had a fascinating conversation
with the CEO of Super Tools,
the productivity company in Israel,
and he's now developing
a new type of calendar
where they're thinking
of taking the ownership over your time-slots
through time blocking
and different best practices.
And one of the things we're talking about
is how we very easily can become slaves
of our own calendars.
And instead of the calendar working for us,
we work for our calendar
and chasing our own tail.
I see that with myself all the time.
So, what can you do though, as an executive?
Because you have everybody
wants to meet you.
Your calendar is full
from like weeks in advance.
So, how do you take ownership
over your time?
How do you actually sit back
and think properly?
What are the priorities
that you should be focused on?
So, I mean,
I think it ties to the word you just said,
which is what of the priorities
you wanna allocate your time.
So, is not whoever wants my time.
Can I have my time?
Right.
You wanna invest your time in there.
And that's different than saying
I'm gonna be accessible
and make time for people to find me
if they need to
But you structure that.
You don't make that on demand
whenever you want.
And I believe strongly that
making time to engage with the broader
set of employees in the organization
is important and certainly with your
direct reports at the next level down.
So, you wanna explicitly
make time for that.
So, that's one of the critical priorities.
Spending time with your
direct reports as an example.
But it really is about being
really rigorous on investing
your time in those areas.
So, one is just know what your
priorities are and you should do it.
The second is we tend to be creatures of
what my calendar says and so if it says
I have a one-hour meeting,
I'm going to have a one-hour meeting.
And the reality is,
if I'm done in 30 minutes,
I'm done with a meeting.
And I find that, I create all sorts
of pockets of time throughout my day.
And used to do this an executive,
because I never went
back to back to back.
I would end things early,
Just because my calendar said
it was an hour,
Didn't mean I was going to take an hour.
So, you're actually the fight
Parkinson's law, right?
Yeah.
The other thing you need to do
is make sure that the people
you're meeting with
are being respectful of your time.
So, for example,
I don't like having meandering meetings
just at random subjects
when I have a one on one.
It's focused on the critical priorities.
How are we doing against them?
How can I help?
What are we doing to get back on track?
And opportunities to give people feedback, etc.
And it doesn't mean you don't allow
some time for chitchat and be asked
on how you doing or things like that.
Because that's important.
It's an important part of a relationship.
And I also just love doing that
as a human being.
But it does mean that you expect
the others to be disciplined about
the conversations they're having.
And the way I do that
is just encourage everyone.
And I talk a lot with entrepreneurs
about this when you're having
one on one with people.
Make sure there's a specific agenda.
This isn't like
what you feel talking about today.
And in general, that agenda should be tied
to what are the most important priorities
that they're working on
to deliver results from the business.
I had one of the most incredible leaders
in my unit in 8200,
that he would not be willing to meet
with anybody unless they send him
an agenda ahead of time.
And it had to be in a proper format
as a part of the calendar invite.
And that was because he was just working,
8AM to 8PM nonstop,
back to back meetings,
that he had to choose
which ones are most important.
But Raymond, then most important question
of the interview so far.
What is this background behind you?
Which beach are we at?
Oh, well, shouldn't I let you guess?
You ought to know.
Given where you come from.
I'm gonna guess Tel Baruch Beach.
But I might be wrong.
It's Banana beach.
Well, I'm from Tel Baruch.
So, this is a,
You know, I was there last summer
having a great visit with family
and also doing a little bit of work
with some of my clients.
And I put it out this June
since we couldn't travel to Israel.
And I just wanted to be reminded
of how wonderful the summer is there.
And you can probably tell
from the plastic chairs
and the plastic bags with all the junk
Yeah. Definitely.
But really, the sunset gives it all
because there's nothing like the
Tel Aviv sunset.
But we're getting way off topic.
Raymond, talk to me a little bit
about scale.
What are some of the key challenges
that entrepreneurs face
as they get to a point
where they're able to scale
their business upwards?
And I’m talking now
as the young entrepreneur myself,
that I didn't have yet the privilege
of getting to that position,
but I can't wait to get there.
And when I do get there,
I want to keep these things in mind.
Right.
So, in my experience,
what makes an entrepreneur
incredibly successful are the things
that can kill them down the road
if they don't adapt.
And so, what do I mean by that?
In the early days, as you know,
and you've talked to many entrepreneurs
and not many but,
you have to do everything yourself.
And by definition,
you're a micromanager.
You're doing everything yourself.
And so, that's one aspect.
And processes even if you have 10 people
who pull them together,
you get in a room,
you talk, you leave.
Right. It's pretty simple.
But as complexity goes up,
those processes break down.
And so, you need to think about
what are some processes
to drive alignment
to know how we're doing.
And that's when companies
start putting in place.
Okay, our processes,
And again, you need to do it
intelligently, not overkill,
and stifle an organization.
So, processes is something
you need to think about.
How you use your own time. Right.
If you hire awesome people
who are world class
when you're scaling and growing
and have the luxury to hire them
because in the early days
you can't hire them.
You can't afford them
and you don't need them.
And so, when you hire them,
the mistake I see entrepreneurs
sometimes make is they still manage them
the way they were micromanaging
when they had four people
in the company.
And the reality is, if you do that,
you'll just piss off a bunch of great people
and they'll leave.
And so, you won't be off the scale
because you won't get the talent
that you need
to build an organization.
So, for me, it comes down primarily to
how you lead and manage
in terms of the role you play.
By enabling others
versus doing it all yourself
and making sure you learn to let go.
Obviously, you've got to trust
those individuals and then
you need to develop that trust.
And then secondly,
putting in place processes
for sort of broader management
of the company.
Whether it's staff meetings,
alignment processes.
Okay our processes
because the processes you used
in the early days just don't scale
when you get past 30 or 40 people.
And certainly, when you
get into the hundreds.
They just don't like.
Doesn't mean you can't keep some
of the cultural aspects
and successful companies do.
Doesn't mean you can can't keep some
elements of those things
like all hands of meetings every Friday
or things like that.
But even that eventually breaks down
when you're in multiple geographies
and people are sleeping doing wrong.
But then as young entrepreneurs,
first time entrepreneurs
going through this journey,
first time you hit employee number 31,
how do you even know what to do?
I mean, it's not like there is a text book
that you can just go to and say,
"Okay. This is how you now can go."
"And these are the processes
you should keep."
"These are the processes you shouldn't."
Maybe an MBA is maybe they have
some relevant classes.
But how do entrepreneurs
get this information?
I mean, I think most of it comes from
just talking to people or experience. Right?
I mean, and then in a large part,
that's the role I play.
But many others do.
There are advisers.
They are experienced people
who can help you do it.
And I think the critical thing
is not to do it when you hit employee 31,
but to anticipate and do it
so that you are there
when you hit employee 31.
And you don't all of a sudden wake up
and go, "Oh, shit, it's not working."
Right.
And so, anticipating those critical milestones
and they're not as hard wired as 30 or 40 or 50,
it's more just thinking about,
"Okay, we've been working
with our friends in a room
and we can talk about priorities
and now we need to start thinking
about more formal process."
And so, what do those look like?
And maybe it's something like,
okay or some other approach
to setting priorities,
maybe at staff meetings
as opposed to informal staff meetings
at some point building a more formality.
And what I mean by that
is going through the critical priorities.
Are we red, yellow, green on these?
Talking about
what we're doing with the red one's
talking about as a team,
how are we going to improve them.
As opposed to a stand up
where we just go around the room
and talk about whatever
we think we want to talk about?
Definitely. Okay.
So, again, it's the anticipation
and putting it in place
so that you don't get,
what ends up happening is
some companies wait too long
and then they grind to a halt
because what ends up happening is
the complexity kills them.
You know, all of a sudden
you can't know everything
that's going on.
You can't keep an organization
completely aligned
when it's a 50, 60, 70 or 100 people.
I love it. Okay.
So, I'm taking priorities
from leadership as an executive.
I'm taking anticipation
as an entrepreneur to scale up.
Let's talk about teams.
What are some of your insights
seeing dozens of entrepreneurs
successful and unsuccessful.
What makes a really, really good team,
not just the founding team,
but being a good, solid team
that is able to take a business,
prove it
and start scaling it upwards.
Yeah, I think, there's are a bunch
of things that make teams great.
And I've learned a lot of this
from some of the great leaders
that I've had the opportunity
to work for.
And so, let me just give you some ideas.
These are not in any particular order.
They're all important.
But a great team gets back to power
if they know what they're solving for.
Right.
And if you randomly grabbed anyone
from that team and said,
"What are the five most important
priorities of the company?"
they ought to be able to answer that.
And if they don't, there's a disconnection.
Teams are really aligned on that.
Is that also important
when the company is huge,
let's say 200 people?
I think certainly an executive team
needs to do it.
I would like for everyone,
but if the people sitting around the table
aren't selling for the same thing.
You've got a problem
sitting around the executive table.
If someone further down the organization
doesn't remember all of that,
but they know what they work on,
and they know ideally, they know
how it supports what a company's
priorities are.
So, yeah, I think this notion of everyone
knows what the critical priorities
are for the organization.
But there a bunch of other aspects, too,
that I kind of alluded to it a second ago.
This alignment piece,
you want to make sure that everyone,
an organization is aligned
in supporting those objectives.
You don't want people
working on stuff that doesn't fit.
Because, one, they're not gonna
feel good about working on stuff
that doesn't matter.
Secondly, it's a waste of resources.
You're not gonna be efficient and optimal
in terms of how you use
your limited capacity.
You know, other things great teams
do really well is they can balance
long term and short term.
You know, it's really easy
to solve for the near-term thing.
And it's really easy
to solve for the long term.
The hard thing is to balance those.
And you need to balance
because you've got to deliver for today.
But you also have to deliver in the future
when the products of today
aren't the most critical ones.
You've got to evolve those products.
You gotta think about new opportunities.
So that's another one
that great teams really do.
They balance those.
And that's a tough thing
because you're always gonna be pushed
to put the resources
on the things that deliver today.
And that's the classic
innovator's dilemma, right?
People, who don't invest in the future.
And I've seen companies get
really screwed by that over time.
The other thing to think about
is that I think great teams do
is they're clear on who owns decisions.
And there's a big difference between
Having input and owning a decision.
Great teams want the best input.
But this isn't a consensus.
Let's vote,
do you wanna be clear on
who owns the decision?
And ultimately,
a CEO owns all decisions
But you wanna be clear on
who owns those so that you can have,
if you aren't clear,
then the organizations are confused.
Or someone makes a decision
and someone overrides a decision.
And so, you want to make sure
that everyone's clear on
who owns the decision.
But at the same time,
allow for the great input.
Because you want the best thinking
brought to bear.
But I could go on with a whole list of things
so, do you want me to keep going
or pick some other topic?
This is just good and I can't believe
20 minutes are almost up.
I'm shocked every single time
and every time I think to myself,
I should have called this show
30-minute leaders.
Not 20-minute leaders.
I don't know why I cut myself short
of ten minutes of pure knowledge.
But Raymond, before we leave,
I want to ask for one key of advice
that you would give me
as a young entrepreneur
soon as starting my entrepreneurial journey,
hopefully sooner rather than later
with my own venture.
What are the two top things
that I should be keeping in mind
as I go on this crazy path?
So, I think the number one thing is
make sure you really believe
in what you're doing.
Because inevitably, I mean,
you've heard this a million times,
at every corner there's gonna be a barrier.
It's hard to raise money.
And even the successful entrepreneurs
will tell you at some point it was hard.
You're gonna have challenges
in doing what you need to do
in terms of managing the product
or creating a brand.
People are gonna tell you, "No."
You're going to struggle getting
distribution deals or whatever it is
you're trying to do
to build your business.
You're gonna lose great people
and you're gonna feel
it's the end of the world
because I just lost my VP of engineering.
And so, you gonna continually
be facing these roadblocks.
And it's really, really hard.
So, you better make sure
you really believe in it and want to do it
and that you're not doing it just because,
"Hey, this is a quick way to make a buck."
And I'm not saying you're doing that at all,
but there are you know,
sometimes I meet entrepreneurs that I,
I don't really get that they
truly, truly believe in it.
And I don't mean in the,
"Hey, I want to change the world."
But they're passionate about what they do
and they're willing to go
through all the battles.
And I think that's the most important.
The second thing I would say
that is most important and it ties to
what we were talking about before,
is really about this being
really, really clear on the critical priorities.
Because your time is so valuable.
You don't have a lot of resources,
either people or money.
So, you've got to make sure
you optimize for those.
And I find too far,
in many cases that entrepreneurs,
they're just trying to do much.
And just declare for yourself what those are
and focus on those
and try not to get sucked
into all the noise around you
because there's got to be plenty of it.
And think about what those critical
things are for your business.
Wonderful.
Raymond, thank you so much
for your time. Toda raba.
It's so generous of you.
But before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
With the explanation or just the words?
With a little explanation
would be wonderful.
Okay.
First and foremost, family.
I love spending time with my wife and kids.
We travel a lot.
Although not recently.
And we're just hanging out at home.
And covid brought even my kid at college.
We're all here together.
And really, the silver lining is all of it.
We're getting to spend
some great time together.
We love spending time together here
up in Tahoe and things like that.
Secondly, it's just, I guess Adaptable.
I've moved around a lot.
I was born in South Africa.
We moved to Israel when I was younger
and then ultimately made our
way to the United States.
And I came at Stanford.
You learn when you're a young kid
moving around a lot, you just learn.
You got to figure out how to survive
and adapt and fit in
and make a go of things.
I can definitely relate to that. Yeah.
And then finally, Ironman. And I've done
Ironman triathlons,
Full Ironman?
Multiple full Ironmans.
We should talk about this the whole time.
Not entrepreneurship.
This is the most interesting.
Wow.
Okay, well, let's set it all up a follow up on this.
But I'm dealing with some injuries now.
So, I'm not sure if there are
any future Ironmans.
But it was a great mental challenge
and physical one, obviously.
So, yeah, those are the three things.
Unbelievable. I was registered
for a half Ironman
in about three days before
covid really took over.
It was up in Napa Valley.
And so, I'm definitely
a way out of shape now.
So, I'm using that as an excuse to say
that if it would have happened,
I would have done it.
Now, I don't feel like I have to do it,
but hopefully I don't.
Is that the one in Santa Rosa?
I think it was.
It's called the Napa Valley Ironman
Okay okay okay.
So, hopefully next year. But we'll see.
Yeah, definitely do it.
And you'll discover it's life changing.
I'm sure. I'm sure.
Raymond, thank you very, very much.
We didn't even talk about J-Ventures.
But I wanna thank you for being so inspiring
and teaching through that as well.
So, thank you for your help over there.
And thank you for your time
and best of luck through this
crazy, crazy time.
My pleasure Michael.